jimena dit aux prises pour toi booba si
je te dis 1986 j'ai juste finale en 1986
tu avais dix ans si je te dis école
jules ferry à meudon
j'avais 10 ans et bâché la faute au
regard du droit sortie celle là oui je
sais mais regarde tu es là aussi les
frais déjà défrayé pourquoi t'as pas
floutés moustache
alors justement non tu il est là à ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta tu te rappelles je crois
même pas s'appelle michel le caire enfin
je m'en rappelle mais c'était s'il ya
combien de temps ça j'avais quoi
ses intérêts c'est excitant 86 m les dix
heureux tullow tuer si tu tombe en panne
et bien avec lui michel aucun souvenir
aucun souvenir de michel chedjou sbee et
ben je te le dis on a retrouvé mes
souvenirs on va voir si souviens toi
parce que michel le caire et ont pissé
dans les trousses aussi quand j'étais
collé à bas j'ai des petits flashs qui
reviennent michel au caire
hélas
aujourd'hui
c'est là bas bonjour monsieur michel pas
debout
merci d'être là oui 2 n'était pas leur
nom ils n'étaient pas propres
je crois vous étiez l'ancien directeur
de l'école sinon ce sont des
irresponsables
il faut un peu dans le dos et vous étiez
également enseignant j'étais enseignant
également aujourd'hui je suis à la
retraite
alors est-ce que vous souvenez mais
aussi bien joué est ce que vous vous
souvenez de booba du petit booba abouba
monsieur booba je me souviens très bien
mais tu te souviens tu vois par exemple
un beat it jouer dans la cour de l'école
à la récré que tu te soumets avec qui tu
jouais je me souviens d'un
en résumé portugais qui avait au moins
50 plus que moi je finis par me tabasser
je traînais avec un vietnamien
s'appelait gérard j'avais mangé des
soupes chinoises enfant terrible et il y
avait alexandre y avait pas virginie les
l'énergie ni l'aîné il y avait certes
remboursions louis bertrand bossions
cyril rial syrie guyane alexandre hollan
dares ça fait 34 ans que je joue avec
eux et il était turbulent ou est-ce
qu'il était sage bas monsieur créé un
petit ange
ouais toujours poli et puis c'était
toujours le premier à lever la main pour
répondre aux questions mais je me
souviens du square avec moi juste une
chose je me souviens également enfin tu
te souviens également que tu t'es des
bagarres et avec le petit laurent gaudé
notamment jeu mais je sais que laurent
gaudé pareil pour un vol de goûter
mais juste après on a fait une grande
mare al mithaq on a fait une grande
barre elle est tout le monde c'est vrai
qu'on saigne est assez beau ca de goûter
octogone mme harel c'est alors une
question pour vous parce que vous avez
suivi ça veut dire gagner la bagarre ça
m'intéresse bah écoute cette fois qu'il
l'a défoncé
c'est un souvenir je me souviens pas je
sais pas si j'ai une question à lui
poser est également mais est ce que tu
te souviens la cantine
tu aimais les fruits cacher la vache qui
rit dans mes poches
je rentrais chez moi les poches voler la
maison gueule parce qu'à tuer mais
rappelle toi tu es mais les pêches
à tel point que tu en étais dans tes
poches pour les ramener pour les manger
à la maison tu aimais les pêches
[Rires]
ma question cellulaire est ce que c'est
pour cette raison un acteur c'est parce
[Musique]
que tu as gardé comme principe de vie
genre de la pêche
[Rires]
je me rappelle de la bâche
alors il paraît que vous avez préparé
une surprise pour booba oui tout à fait
vous avez un peu de musique
[Musique]
[Rires]
louh a dit alors c'est pas mieux le 15,6
me disait avec les gens de détecter on
ne la fait pas à moi et jean-claude
incroyable